Merci, Stuart.
Nous sommes heureux
de vous avoir avec nous.
Laurent Vallet en a parlé précédemment,
plaisantant sur le titre :
Propagande et Démocratie,
et sur le fait que ces deux mots,
bien qu'ils semblent
antagonistes et contraires,
ne sont pas si éloignés
l'un de l'autre.
Tout votre travail
et ce que nous avons vu
dans le documentaire le montrent.
Nous sommes dans un monde différent
aujourd'hui,
ou nous pensons
être dans un monde différent,
différent de celui d'Edward Bernays.
Est-il vraiment différent ?
Quelle serait sa réaction,
s'il revenait aujourd'hui ?
Il est mort à plus de 100 ans.
Il avait 102 ans à sa mort.
Il n'était pas véritablement impliqué
dans le monde numérique,
mais quelle serait sa réaction
s'il revenait,
face à nos algorithmes, le big data,
cette technologie qui a envahi
chaque domaine de notre vie ?
Je pense que nous sommes persuadés
que tout est nouveau.
Nous aimons bien penser
que nous avançons dans la vie.
Ça fait partie aussi de la façon
dont les médias fonctionnent,
les médias d'information, notamment,
avec un cycle de 24 heures
dans les informations.
Une partie de ce que font les médias,
c'est qu'ils se reposent sur le fait
que chaque journée apporte du nouveau,
c'est pour ça qu'on dit
que ce sont des nouvelles.
Le résultat, c'est que...
cela promeut une certaine fascination
pour les nouveautés du présent,
tout en oblitérant d'autres choses.
Chaque journée consume
les informations de la veille
et génère une amnésie historique,
qui nous empêche de sentir...
l'ombre des écrits d'Edward Bernays
planer sur nous.
Mais Bernays serait très heureux
de l'avènement des technologies
utilisées aujourd'hui comme le big data.
On sait qu'elles sont le diagnostic
des sentiments profonds des gens
à travers leur comportement en ligne.
Il se dirait :
"C'est exactement ce que je cherchais.
"Dans les années 1920,
"je voulais tout d'abord comprendre
quelles étaient les motivations
"derrière le public ou les masses.
"Je voulais aussi comprendre
"ce qu'un sociologue français
de l'entre-deux siècles,
"Gabriel Tarde qui parlait d'opinion
et de conversation,
"avait dit en 1898:
" 'Les gens sont autour d'une table,
ont une conversation
" 'mais croient qu'ils ne sont
que deux ou trois à l'avoir.' "
Le rôle du journalisme
et celui des médias
arrivent à un point
où leurs conversations
ne sont plus leurs conversations.
Leurs esprits et leurs mots suivent
"le sillon des idées qu'ils empruntent".
Et donc même dès cette époque-là,
Bernays cherchait
quels étaient les rails,
pour ainsi dire, ou les réseaux,
empruntés par la perception,
dans la société.
L'utilisation du big data,
qui est devenu
un mot-clé du présent,
une expression-clé du présent,
c'est tout simplement quelque chose
qui affine
ce que Bernays cherchait,
en termes plus primitifs,
quand il a commencé son travail,
au cours
de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Donc, vous croyez que les fondamentaux
de sa réflexion, de sa théorie,
sont toujours présents
et que tout
ce que nous avons changé,
ce sont l'échelle, les outils,
les capacités
d'atteindre l'esprit des gens
et leurs comportements ?
Mais fondamentalement,
rien n'a changé.
Si vous regardez
quelles sont les motivations,
quelles sont les stratégies,
elles n'ont pas changé,
mais les outils, eux, ont changé.
Ce qui est intéressant...
On a entendu Jimmy Leipold parler
du livre de Bernays,
Propaganda,
publié en France il n'y a que 10 ans.
Il a été republié aux États-Unis,
au cours de la dernière décennie.
Bernays, c'était un nom.
Étudiant,
on m'a raconté cette anecdote :
Beethoven et Hegel,
le philosophe,
étaient sur le bord de la route,
et Napoléon
est passé à cheval.
Hegel se tourna
vers Beethoven et lui dit:
"Nous sommes témoins
de l'esprit du monde
"qui monte sur ses grands chevaux."
Et Beethoven
n'a jamais reparlé à Hegel.
Bernays représente l'esprit du monde
des marionnettistes cachés,
dont le but est de diriger,
non pas le consentement public,
mais on en parlait à table,
tout à l'heure...
"La fabrique du consentement",
c'est une façon trop gentille
de le dire,
parce que ce dont on parle en réalité,
c'est la fabrique de l'obéissance.
Et c'est important.
C'est une constante de notre monde
et très certainement aux États-Unis.
Il n'y a aucune autre façon
de comprendre le Trumpisme,
sans voir en cela
le produit de la fabrique
de l'obéissance.
On parlera Trump, à l'évidence.
C'est une partie importante
de notre discussion.
Mais pour continuer sur cet aspect,
lorsque l'Internet et les compagnies
de technologie sont arrivés,
on les a considérés
comme des outils de libération,
de liberté,
changeant ce paradigme
que vous avez décrit.
Particulièrement
quand on parle du slogan de Google :
"Ne soyez pas malveillants."
Comment cela se fait-il
qu'on ne l'ait pas vu, au début ?
Question compliquée,
parce que l'Internet a été développé
par l'armée américaine,
pas simplement par un petit groupe
en quête de liberté.
Il y a un livre qui a été publié
récemment aux États-Unis,
dont le titre échappe à ma vieille tête,
qui traite de cette étrange relation
entre le militaire
et l'utilisation de l'Internet.
Mais ce que beaucoup de gens ont vu,
c'était que l'Internet
créait l'espace public,
où tout le monde pouvait
prendre part aux débats.
C'était fondamental
pour l'idée de la démocratie,
telle qu'elle a été développée au XVIIIe
ici, aux États-Unis et ailleurs.
Mais en France et aux États-Unis,
principalement.
La différence bien sûr,
c'est qu'Internet est un espace public,
où les individus sont isolés.
Les relations entre cet espace public
et les possibilités
de prises de conscience publique,
en tant que public
prônant discussions publiques
et activisme public,
sont très compliquées à mettre en place,
parce que les gens
sont devant leurs petits écrans,
témoins de l'histoire
de façon extrêmement isolée.
Tout en offrant la possibilité
d'une sorte d'interaction,
qui était auparavant inimaginable,
ça crée aussi un public beaucoup
plus solitaire, individualisé, isolé,
ce qui génère un terrible problème
pour notre avenir.
Qui serait l'Edward Bernays
d'aujourd'hui ?
Ce serait un ingénieur
en informatique
qui conçoit des algorithmes ?
Une des raisons pour lesquelles
Edward Bernays est intéressant,
a été traduit il y a 10 ans en français,
a été publié puis republié en anglais,
il y a moins de dix ans,
aux États-Unis,
avec son livre précédent,
qui s'appelait
Cristalliser l'opinion publique,
originellement publié en 1923...
L'une des raisons pour lesquelles
Bernays est republié donc,
c'est parce qu'il parle
à la génération d'aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire...
Je connais beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont impliqués
dans des formes contemporaines
de la persuasion et de l'influence,
qui retournent vers Bernays
et le voient comme...
On pourrait dire le pape,
vu comme le primat,
le saint primat de la persuasion.
Une des raisons pour laquelle le film
de Jimmy Leipold a une résonance,
c'est que de bien des manières,
Bernays,
comme je l'ai dit précédemment,
est l'esprit du monde de notre temps.
Il n'était pas seul, il y en avait
beaucoup d'autres comme lui.
Une des raisons pour laquelle
on le connaît,
c'est parce qu'il a écrit sur lui-même,
pas comme la plupart des gens des RP,
qui préfèrent l'ombre,
lui s'est auto-promu.
Outre ses ouvrages des années 1920,
il a écrit un livre,
son autobiographie
appelée Autobiographie d'une idée,
où il prenait l'idée de la propagande
et se l'appropriait.
Mais Bernays faisait partie
d'une génération de gens
qui avaient travaillé pour la machine
de propagande militaire,
qui s'appelait
"Le Comité pour l'information publique",
au cours de la Première Guerre mondiale.
À l'époque, ces gens
qui provenaient des médias,
étaient des spécialistes
de la persuasion, des publicistes,
des journalistes,
des réalisateurs de films, des orateurs,
avaient été recrutés par la Commission,
aussi appelée "Commission Creel"
dans le film,
du nom de son dirigeant.
La Commission Creel a été démantelée
sept jours après l'Armistice.
Il y avait tout un groupe de gens
qui venaient du journalisme local,
de la radio, du cinéma, etc.
et qui avaient compris
l'intérêt de porter leur travail
à une échelle nationale
et internationale.
Donc, il y eut l'émergence,
dans les années 1920,
de ce qu'un universitaire a appelé
"les professions du consentement".
Bernays était un homme de son temps,
ce n'était pas un individu isolé.
La raison pour laquelle
il est devenu si influent,
c'est qu'en fait,
lui savait ce qu'il faisait.
Bernays parle aux gens d'aujourd'hui.
Les jeunes dont je parlais
qui sont dans le guérilla marketing,
la réalité virtuelle,
la gestion de données et son marché,
ce sont des gens
qui voient en Bernays leur leader,
d'où ses republications.
Vous avez mentionné Trump,
et sa victoire
a ouvert la voie à beaucoup de questions,
beaucoup de débats
qui sont au cœur
des sujets mondiaux d'aujourd'hui,
sur les fake news, la manipulation
et la post-vérité.
Ces concepts, ils existaient,
mais ont éclaté
et sont entrés dans le débat public
après la victoire de Donald Trump.
"Les faits alternatifs", par exemple,
un autre de ces concepts.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Qu'est-ce que Trump a déclenché ?
On parle d'Edward Bernays,
de la manipulation,
de façonner l'opinion publique.
Qu'est-ce que Donald Trump
nous dit à ce sujet ?
Un des points principaux
au sujet de Trump,
c'est qu'il a mis le monde
sens dessus dessous.
C'est-à-dire...
La vérité a toujours été
une conséquence des idées,
le journalisme n'est pas simplement
un rassemblement scientifique de données,
qui sont ensuite
présentées au grand public,
de façon totalement objective.
Le journalisme a toujours eu
des motifs et des visions sous-jacents.
Il y a 100 ans, William James,
le philosophe américain,
a écrit un livre
qui s'appelle Pragmatisme.
Je l'ai cité dans PR,
un livre que j'ai écrit il y a 22 ans
et regardez, je suis là aujourd'hui.
Une des choses qu'il a écrites
dans son livre sur le pragmatisme,
dans un chapitre intitulé
"Le Concept de vérité du pragmatisme",
c'est que la vérité n'est pas
quelque chose d'inhérent en soi,
la vérité est le produit d'une idée,
ça devient la vérité par un processus
de présentation et de vérification.
C'est vraiment une vision
très intéressante.
Parce que d'un côté,
c'est une idée extrêmement démocratique,
l'idée qu'il ne faut pas
accepter des vérités
qui nous sont données
par des rois et des papes.
D'un autre, ça amène l'idée que,
si la vérité est le produit d'une idée,
alors si vous l'assénez suffisamment,
ça devient la vérité.
Et pendant longtemps aux États-Unis,
les médias reconnus
comme le New York Times,
la chaîne CBS,
le Washington Post, etc.,
étaient les institutions
qui avaient l'imprimatur de la vérité.
J'ai lu l'édition internationale
du New York Times,
très différente
de celle que l'on a chez nous.
Elle est beaucoup plus critique
que ce que nous avons au pays.
Mais il manque le slogan en haut,
que nous avons sur notre édition.
À droite, c'est la météo,
et à gauche, il y a ce slogan :
"Toutes les informations
qui méritent d'être imprimées."
Ce que ça signifie,
c'est que pendant très longtemps,
il y avait ces autorités
qui semblaient être les étendards,
non pas de la vérité divine,
mais des recherches
qui devenaient vérités.
Il y avait une certaine arrogance
qui accompagnait ce fait.
C'est très différent de la France,
nous n'avons jamais eu
de journaux comme Libération.
On n'a jamais eu un journalisme
qui était vraiment diversifié.
Nos partis ne le sont même pas.
On a les deux faces de la même pièce
dans notre système politique.
Ce que Trump a fait,
ça a été de, comme je le disais...
Il a mis le monde sens dessus dessous.
Il a transformé
les canaux traditionnels de la vérité
en fournisseurs de mensonges.
Et ils l'étaient, en partie.
Le New York Times
a vendu la guerre en Irak
aux Américains
en prônant un journalisme préemballé
par l'armée américaine...
Ce n'est que deux, trois ans après...
Que les journaux ont commencé
leur propre auto-critique.
Exactement.
Ces journaux
se sont lancés dans l'auto-critique
après avoir vendu l'idée
des armes de destruction massive
entre autres choses.
C'était comme
un théâtre de marionnettes.
Ce que Trump a compris,
c'est que tant qu'on a un système
où il y aura des marionnettistes
impliqués dans la présentation
des informations, alors...
certains secteurs du public américain
se sentiront exclus
ou privés de la vision de la vérité
présentée par ces médias.
C'est très facile pour beaucoup de gens
d'imaginer les médias traditionnels
ou commerciaux,
travaillant tous
pour le même système industriel,
qui s'est effondré en 2008
au niveau planétaire.
De les voir comme une machine
de propagande.
Et donc Trump a pris le terme propagande,
ou fake news,
qui est une autre façon
de dire la chose,
et l'a projeté
sur les grands médias traditionnels.
Est-ce que cela signifie
que dans ce contexte,
Trump représenterait
un mouvement de résistance
face à Edward Bernays
et sa fabrique du consentement ?
Je ne pense pas.
Mais il comprend Bernays
mieux que le New York Times.
Il les a pris à leur propre jeu.
Vous savez,
vous avez parlé au départ
de la terminologie de la propagande
et de la démocratie.
Il y a beaucoup
de ces contradictions apparentes
qui sont vivantes dans notre monde.
Il y a un écrivain aux États-Unis,
qui a vécu à Paris
pendant un certain temps,
Ta-Nehisi Coates,
il a produit un excellent
travail de journaliste
dans son livre :
Plaidoyer pour une réparation,
sur l'histoire des politiques
qui sous-tendent
le système du racisme aux États-Unis.
Particulièrement
en ce qui concerne les Noirs.
Et une des choses qu'il dit,
c'est que la démocratie
et la suprématie blanche
vont de pair.
Et c'est probablement aussi vrai
en France qu'aux États-Unis.
- On n'est pas tellement différents.
- Non.
Le colonialisme
et l'impérialisme américain
sont différents moments
mais s'inscrivent dans une même tendance.
La propagande a été développée
en raison de la démocratie.
Bernays s'y était intéressé.
Puisque les gens
avaient cette idée arrogante
de croire que leurs idées
et leurs pensées étaient importantes,
Bernays s'était rendu compte
que les vieux systèmes de règles
ne fonctionnaient plus :
l'aristocratie,
la hiérarchie ecclésiastique,
cela ne voulait plus rien dire.
Ce qui était nécessaire,
c'était la création
d'ingénieurs invisibles,
qui auraient des outils scientifiques
pour gérer la démocratie,
afin que les gens
puissent continuer à croire
que leur propre voix était entendue.
Et que dans le même temps,
le pouvoir exécutif
puisse faire ce qu'il voulait.
Ce que Trump a fait,
c'est qu'il a lié sa politique
à certains sentiments
qui prévalent aux États-Unis.
Revenons à Ta-Nehisi Coates.
Cette idée de suprématie blanche
est quelque chose qui va donner
même aux Blancs les plus pauvres
un sentiment de supériorité,
un sentiment d'importance,
de sorte que les gens de couleur
ne sont pas importants.
Ça donne aux Blancs
un sentiment d'importance.
Et une partie de ce qui se produit,
dans cette période
qui suit la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
et plus particulièrement
entre les années 1950 à 1970,
c'est que ces points de vue,
autrefois enfouis,
vont soudain avoir à nouveau une voix.
Des livres vont être publiés
par des soi-disant analphabètes.
Trump a senti le ressentiment
que cela générait.
Lui-même est un produit
de ce ressentiment.
Le père de Trump,
c'est de lui qu'il tient son argent,
était dans l'immobilier.
Il avait interdit aux Noirs d'habiter
dans les lotissements qu'il construisait.
Son père marchait main dans la main
avec le Ku Klux Klan dans les années 1920.
La famille de Trump est liée
à la suprématie blanche,
et le fait d'appeler les Mexicains
des violeurs et des criminels,
ce n'est pas différent
de ce que le KKK disait
des Noirs à la fin du XIXe.
Ce que Trump fait,
je pense que vous l'avez remarqué,
à la différence de tous
les hommes politiques que j'ai vus,
quand il parle,
et il tient des meetings tout le temps...
Je n'ai jamais vu un Président
qui tenait des meetings
tous les deux jours,
et dans ces meetings,
il va dans des endroits
qui sont en faveur de ses idées :
la volonté de rendre le pouvoir
à ceux qui n'ont pas de pouvoir,
et de défendre la suprématie blanche,
contre la mainmise des autres
qui transforment les États-Unis
en un endroit qu'on ne reconnaît plus.
Il fait ses discours,
mais chaque fois,
il recrute des gens
qui se tiennent derrière lui.
Donc quand vous le voyez
dans un meeting,
ce n'est pas simplement Trump
sur un podium,
mais il y a des centaines
de personnes derrière lui
qui ont été formées par quelqu'un,
pour acclamer follement chaque chose
qu'il va dire,
et qui sont aussi,
comment dirais-je,
une mosaïque de petites représentations
de la diversité,
donc vous allez voir un visage noir.
Et ce visage surmonte un corps
enveloppé dans un tee-shirt blanc
où est écrit : "Les Noirs pour Trump !"
Il y a deux femmes
en dépit de la misogynie
qui prévaut dans son mouvement
qui sont les
"femmes en faveur de Trump",
mais pour la plupart,
c'est une bande de camionneurs
aux casquettes rouges
arborant le slogan :
"Pour que l'Amérique
soit grande à nouveau",
ce qui pour beaucoup de gens signifie :
"Pour que l'Amérique
soit blanche à nouveau"
et qu'elle tire un trait sur son passé.
De bien des façons,
c'est l'utilisation de ce symbolisme :
être un homme du peuple,
et l'avoir derrière soi sur scène.
Ça, c'est remarquable,
notamment parce que ça provient
d'une espèce de génie intuitif.
Je crois que c'est le cas.
C'est pas un intellectuel, Trump.
Véritablement,
il joue sur l'anti-intellectualisme,
qui est une des lignes directrices
de la société américaine.
Il fait du Bernays sans l'avoir lu ?
Il connaît quelqu'un qui a lu Bernays.
Probablement.
Mais pour la plus grande part,
son style,
dans la culture populaire américaine,
est lié au cinéma américain.
Dans la culture populaire américaine,
il y a deux genres dominants de films.
Le premier, c'est le western.
John Wayne, et bien d'autres.
Le western met l'accent sur l'individu
qui n'obéit à personne d'autre
qu'à lui-même.
Et d'une certaine manière,
c'est une représentation
du comportement libertarien,
de celui qui est prêt à tuer
n'importe qui se mettra sur sa route.
Ça fait partie du charme horrible
de la tradition du western.
L'autre tradition,
ce sont les films de gangsters.
Il sort d'un film de gangsters.
Il faut vous rendre compte
qu'il vient de l'industrie du bâtiment.
Toute personne qui a passé
suffisamment de temps à New York,
à regarder comment
l'industrie du bâtiment fonctionne,
sait que cette branche,
historiquement,
avec d'autres
comme l'assainissement privé,
ont été dirigées par la mafia
ou d'autres organisations criminelles.
Si vous voulez faire des affaires
à New York,
il faut savoir à qui verser
un dessous de table.
Il faut savoir à qui faire confiance
et à qui ne pas faire confiance.
Il y a un lien secret qui se développe
entre vous et les gens que vous payez.
Ce lien secret est basé sur l'idée
que vous les payez,
mais si jamais ils vous dénoncent,
vous, vous allez les éliminer.
Lorsque les gens
de l'entourage de Trump
sont sous le coup d'une enquête
et le dénoncent,
il utilise le langage des gangs
pour en parler.
"Celui-là, c'est un mec bien,
un gars loyal, l'un des nôtres.
"Lui, c'est une balance."
Je ne saurais pas dire ça en français.
Mais c'est la langue du gangster !
Et toute personne qui travaille
dans certains domaines à New York,
et c'est vrai depuis très longtemps...
J'ai grandi avec ces gens-là.
Les pères de beaucoup de mes amis
étaient gangsters.
J'ai grandi dans le Queens
pendant longtemps.
C'est de là que vient Trump.
C'est un monde infiltré
par le gangstérisme.
Je le comprends instantanément,
car je travaille dans une université
régie par le système politique
de New York.
J'ai vu des paquets d'argent
au sein de l'université,
où des doyens donnaient de l'argent
à des professeurs obéissants, pour rien.
"Tu es mon copain,
on prend un pot après le travail ?
"Tiens, voilà 100 000 $,
prends du bon temps."
Donc, ça fait partie de la culture.
Ce côté de Trump séduit.
Les criminels dans les films de gangsters
et dans les westerns
sont toujours les héros.
Les tueurs sont toujours romantiques.
Le fait d'enfiler sa casquette
de baseball rouge,
symbole de la culture des camionneurs,
et qui est aussi
le symbole d'une autre industrie :
les Teamsters, qui ont eux-mêmes
un passé d'association criminelle,
nous montre qu'en réalité
il est entouré de gens
qui viennent de ce milieu véreux,
de gens peu recommandables.
Un des aspects les plus frappants
de la scène américaine,
vu d'ici, en tout cas,
c'est la polarisation :
le fait que les Américains
ne lisent pas les mêmes informations,
ne croient pas les mêmes sources.
On est soit Fox News,
soit New York Times.
La base pour la société,
pour la communauté, n'existe plus.
Est-ce quelque chose
que Trump utilise ?
Tout d'abord, c'est quelque chose
qui s'est produit
lorsqu'on a remplacé les cheminées
par la télévision,
ce qui d'ailleurs...
Vous êtes un grand pessimiste.
Non, un optimiste.
Parce que je pense que le changement,
c'est difficile.
On en a déjà parlé.
Nous vivons dans un monde,
certainement aux États-Unis,
où les gens veulent la récompense
tout de suite.
Ils veulent un changement immédiat.
En tant qu'historien,
ce que l'on sait,
c'est que le changement,
ça prend du temps.
Je crois qu'avec
cette division de la société
et l'utilisation du big data
pour la systématiser,
cela se sait désormais,
il y a une insatisfaction grandissante.
Quand Trump va dans le Michigan
ou n'importe quel endroit,
et qu'il y a cette foule
qui applaudit derrière,
elle a été formée pour ça.
Quand les reporters demandent :
"Dit-il quelque chose qui vous énerve ?"
Les gens disent :
"Non, je crois tout ce qu'il dit."
Ils ne sont même pas dans la démocratie,
ils sont tombés amoureux de Trump.
Ils ont projeté sur lui les choses
qu'ils ont senties
et qu'ils n'osaient pas dire.
Ils projettent sur lui ce qui leur manque
dans leur propre vie.
Simultanément, la population
des États-Unis est en train de changer.
On s'organise en masse,
au niveau local.
Les gens se rencontrent de façon
très prometteuse, je trouve.
Le fait qu'un socialiste
ou quelques socialistes
soient arrivés à des positions de pouvoir
aux États-Unis,
c'est quelque chose
qui ne s'est pas produit depuis 100 ans.
Vous aviez à peine quelques personnes...
Vous faites référence à quoi ?
Aux candidats des primaires ?
Aux primaires démocrates
pour les élections de mi-mandat.
À New York...
Les républicains...
Ça aussi, c'est intéressant
au sujet de Trump.
Il est haï dans sa propre ville.
Nous, on a reçu
une grande dose de Trump,
depuis l'époque où il était un play-boy
sur la couverture
du magazine The Enquirer.
Les gens
ont une très mauvaise opinion de lui.
Il fait partie de la mythologie
américaine de l'escroc des villes
qui va essayer de profiter
des bonnes gens dans les bourgades.
Mais cette fois-ci,
les bonnes gens aiment ça.
D'autres choses se produisent.
Il y a eu une recherche récente
menée sur la population
des États-Unis.
En 2018, le pourcentage
de la population née à l'étranger
est plus important
que ça ne l'a jamais été depuis 1910,
c'est-à-dire au milieu
de cette grande période de migration
de gens qui venaient du Mezzogiorno,
en Italie,
ou provenant de l'Europe de l'Est.
Ces gens ont été
aussi maltraités, à l'époque.
Trump est une espèce
de résurgence de ces anciennes...
de ces forces anti-immigration
de l'époque,
les gens qui promouvaient l'eugénisme
pour tenter de diminuer la fertilité
des êtres inférieurs,
responsables aussi
de tentatives réussies, d'ailleurs,
contre les Noirs
pour les décourager
ou les empêcher,
de façon violente parfois,
de voter.
Trump nous fait retourner violemment
vers cette démagogie
qui a inspiré Bernays ou Gustave Le Bon.
Ce n'est pas un technocrate
ni un homme qui...
Mais pour poursuivre
sur ce que vous avez dit
dans les dernières pages
de votre livre PR,
vous êtes un optimiste, c'est vrai,
sur l'influence de l'éducation
et sur l'éducation aux médias.
Vous dites que par comparaison
avec le début du XXe,
il y a à l'évidence un accès
beaucoup plus important à l'information,
au savoir,
ces choses-là se sont démocratisées,
se sont ouvertes.
Et puis,
au cours des 20 dernières années,
on a ce sentiment
qu'on fait un retour en arrière.
L'histoire
ne va pas toujours de l'avant.
Ça fait partie de ces idées
des Lumières,
du progrès,
mais je dirais deux choses,
de ce point de vue-là.
Si vous concluez un livre
sur le pouvoir de la persuasion,
vous devez parler des marionnettistes
qui sont derrière l'instrumentalisation
de la persuasion,
et il faut encourager le lecteur
à croire qu'il y a une possibilité
d'avoir quelque chose de mieux,
parce que si l'étude des médias
se cantonne à voir comment ceux-ci
nous niquent la tête...
Pardonnez mon langage...
En anglais, on dirait :
"Pardonnez mon français..."
Donc si c'est tout ce que vous faites,
alors vous encouragez les gens
à avoir ce sentiment d'impuissance.
Et autre chose au sujet
de l'impuissance,
c'est que ça rend les gens impuissants.
Il est important que les gens
imaginent leur puissance potentielle,
pas en tant qu'individus,
mais en tant que peuple, que Terriens.
L'éducation aux médias
est un sujet intéressant,
parce qu'on parle beaucoup
de cela en France.
Le gouvernement a annoncé
qu'il allait doubler les budgets
pour l'éducation aux médias à l'école.
C'est vu comme une façon
de s'opposer aux fake news,
aux théories du complot,
pour créer de meilleurs citoyens futurs.
Il n'y a pas de véritable preuve
que ça fonctionne
quand vous regardez les États-Unis.
Tout d'abord,
il faut commencer par l'alphabétisation,
et ce que ça veut dire.
Est-ce que cela signifie
que comme disaientcertaines personnes,
au début du XXe,
dans le monde des affaires :
"Il faut apprendre
aux gens à lire et écrire
"pour qu'ils puissent mieux
obéir aux ordres" ?
L'alphabétisation a une histoire.
La plupart des gens dans l'Histoire
n'étaient pas alphabétisés.
Et la raison pour laquelle
l'alphabétisation est devenue un souci,
notamment lors de mouvements sociaux
du XVIIIe au XXe,
c'est parce que l'alphabétisation
n'est pas simplement...
Quand on enseignait à lire et écrire
aux enfants, au XIXe,
quand on les alphabétisait,
ce n'était pas pour qu'ils comprennent
les mensonges des livres.
Il faut donc le savoir
et faire attention à ça.
Il faut comprendre comment
la rhétorique d'un côté,
si utilisée correctement,
peut éclairer les gens,
ou si, utilisée à contre-emploi,
elle peut aussi masquer la réalité
et faire que les gens travaillent
contre leur propre intérêt.
L'idée de l'alphabétisation
et les mouvements en faveur de celle-ci...
Les mouvements en faveur
de l'alphabétisation...
Les campagnes
en faveur de l'éducation
ont été au cœur
des mouvements sociaux populaires
car ils permettaient
d'élargir l'univers du débat.
L'idée n'était pas simplement
d'apprendre à lire,
mais d'apprendre à écrire,
et mettre en avant
l'idée qu'apprendre ceci
allait élargir
le spectre d'idées possibles,
émises par des gens
qui, historiquement,
avaient été ignorés
au cours de l'Histoire.
Bien que cela soit vrai,
nous sommes à une époque sombre
du développement de l'utilisation
de la psychologie des masses
instrumentalisée pour mobiliser des gens
de façon extrêmement dangereuse.
Et dans le même temps,
c'est une époque
où il y a une explosion d'écrits
qui donnent la voix
à des idées insolites.
Je parlais de Ta-Nehisi Coates
et son Plaidoyer pour une réparation,
qui porte
sur le racisme institutionnalisé,
sur les assassinats des Noirs
par la police,
qui font partie
des informations quotidiennes.
Il dit: "Ce n'est pas nouveau,
"c'est quelque chose qui se produit
"parce qu'il y a une histoire
de différentes politiques
"qui ont assuré
la ghettoïsation des Noirs."
D'une certaine manière,
c'est rendre le présent lisible
en fournissant au public
une mémoire historique.
C'est une des tâches
de l'alphabétisation, et ça se produit.
Le film de Jimmy Leipold s'inscrit
dans cet univers de discussions possibles.
Vous avez été très critique
envers les médias aux États-Unis,
mais ça pourrait s'appliquer
à la France et à l'Europe
de la même manière, si vous viviez ici.
Certaines de ces critiques
sont légitimes très certainement
et partagées par beaucoup de personnes.
Mais dans le même temps,
l'alternative n'est pas apparue
et les réseaux sociaux
ont été considérés un certain temps...
Je le sais, car quand on a lancé
notre site Web "Rue89",
on imaginait que les gens
s'approprieraient ces réseaux sociaux
pour donner,
non pas des informations alternatives,
mais pour mieux traiter et plus largement
les informations,
et ça ne s'est pas produit du tout.
- Du tout.
Et aujourd'hui, nous faisons face
à des médias décrédibilisés...
Je crois que j'ai inventé un mot...
Des médias moins crédibles
et des réseaux sociaux
qui sont devenus des champs de bataille
pour des idéologies rivales
ou des groupes haineux.
Ce qu'il nous reste,
c'est un système de l'information
qui est moins fiable et crédible.
Le système de l'information
a contribué à cela,
à cause du simple fait
que chaque jour
il faille sortir un nouveau journal
qui contient des choses nouvelles,
et Trump est fantastique pour ça.
Une des choses dont Le Bon
a parlé au sujet des dirigeants
à la fin du XIXe...
Désolé de revenir en arrière
pour parler du présent,
mais je pense
que la mémoire est importante.
La perte de mémoire
ou la déliquescence de celle-ci
est un des plus grands périls à venir
pour notre civilisation.
Dans le livre de Ray Bradbury
Fahrenheit 451,
on voit l'avènement
d'un monde dystopique,
car personne
ne pouvait plus se souvenir de rien.
C'est l'oblitération de la mémoire.
Quand Gustave Le Bon
regardait les dirigeants
de la fin du XIXe...
La Commune de Paris,
ça l'a vraiment rendu fou.
Il a remarqué
que les dirigeants parlaient en images.
Chaque image suit l'image précédente,
comme dans une lanterne magique.
Elles n'ont pas de lien,
les unes avec les autres,
et semblent prouver
qu'elles n'ont pas de connexion logique,
mais deviennent une sorte
de pseudo-narration.
C'est ce que fait Tweeter.
Tweeter est la lanterne magique
d'aujourd'hui.
Le fait qu'on ait un Président
sur Twitter 10 fois par jour
est une façon de créer
un constant détournement d'attention
du monde, en général.
Mais je vais revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit au départ.
Vous avez dit
que j'étais critique envers les médias.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
Les médias sont des outils
d'expression publique.
Je ne suis pas un critique
de la presse imprimée.
Elle peut être utilisée comme moyen
d'émancipation de la population
mais aussi comme moyen d'oppression.
La véritable question,
et elle est au cœur
de celle de l'alphabétisation,
c'est de savoir on est sérieux
quand on parle d'éducation aux médias.
L'éducation aux médias
implique d'encourager le public
à ne pas naïvement lire l'information
ou la désinformation des médias,
mais aussi à en étudier les structures,
de manière à savoir
si celles-ci l'empêcheront
de faire ce qui est nécessaire
pour accomplir
son aspiration démocratique.
Autre chose est nécessaire :
abattre le distinguo
entre auteur et public.
En d'autres termes,
faire du journalisme citoyen.
Ça a un impact extrêmement positif
aux États-Unis, en tout cas.
Le meurtre d'Eric Garner
par un policier sur Staten Island
fait partie de l'histoire américaine.
Les policiers tuent des Noirs
depuis qu'il y a des Noirs libres.
Et même lorsqu'ils n'étaient pas libres,
les contremaîtres les tuaient.
La différence, c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on parle de ces exactions.
Les gens devraient s'imaginer
en citoyens journalistes
et imaginer des façons
de se réunir en tant que communauté.
En d'autres termes,
quand quelqu'un dit...
J'ai donné une interview
il y a deux jours,
et l'intervieweur m'a dit:
"Qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à quelqu'un qui dit :
" 'Je ne veux pas être manipulé' " ?
À quelqu'un qui ne veut pas l'être ?
Je lui dirais :
"Aussi longtemps
que vous vous voyez comme quelqu'un,
"vous êtes susceptible d'être manipulé."
Ce n'est qu'en comprenant
que nous sommes des Terriens,
comme faisant partie d'une espèce
qui a besoin de se redécouvrir,
c'est simplement quand cela se produit
que l'on peut créer des médias
qui seront critiques et interactifs...
Pas interactifs en ligne,
mais interactifs dans la rue.
La rue, c'est très important,
parce que quand les gens s'y réunissent,
le pouvoir tremble.
Lorsque les gens se réunissent en ligne,
cela repose la question
du contrôle des structures des médias.
Et qui contrôle
les plateformes technologiques ?
Les plateformes numériques ?
Facebook, Google, Twitter, etc.
C'est une des choses qui...
Ce sont des alliés ou des ennemis
dans ce que vous venez de décrire ?
C'est intéressant, car si vous regardez
les sociétés de la Silicon Valley...
Je ne suis pas au fait
des équivalents français...
Mais si vous regardez...
Nous utilisons Twitter, Facebook, etc.
Les Chinois ont développé
des alternatives, par exemple.
Rendez-vous compte
que les gens de la Silicon Valley
sont dans cette contradiction
intéressante.
Ils sont socialement très progressifs
et tendent à l'être en termes d'idées,
de droits des genres,
d'orientation sexuelle, etc.
Et ils soutiennent
des causes "libérales",
à une exception :
le type à la tête de PayPal...
Peter Thiel était un soutien de Trump.
Les autres étaient
des "fonctionnaires" d'Obama.
Mais ils sont tous fortement libertariens
et d'une manière convergente.
Par exemple,
lorsque le gouvernement
veut les réglementer
d'une manière ou d'une autre,
ils adoptent la même position
que l'industrie du pétrole,
la même position
que d'autres monopoles mondiaux
ont adoptée depuis les premiers jours
du libre-échange.
Et donc émerge une situation
où se crée une sorte
de corporatisme transnational.
C'est l'état d'esprit économique
de la Silicon Valley
et une sorte d'intérêt de pure forme
pour la doctrine libertarienne
qui fonctionne
à un niveau plus démocratique.
Pour en revenir à notre discussion,
le problème,
c'est que les propriétaires,
les capitaines de ces industries
comprennent les buts lucratifs,
et c'est ce qui les motive.
Un grand nombre de gens
qui travaillent pour eux,
ingénieurs informaticiens
ou autres,
sont des libertariens
qui ne s'identifient pas
aux motivations capitalistiques.
Quelqu'un comme Edward Snowden,
vient de ce monde
et s'est éloigné des politiques
de la NSA,
mais aussi de Silicon Valley.
Mais Silicon Valley,
c'est la nouvelle colonne vertébrale
du capitalisme américain ?
- Oui.
Absolument, et c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles,
quand on parle
de créer des médias alternatifs,
il faut trouver d'autres canaux,
en construire d'autres
et aller probablement plus
vers la low-tech,
parce que la haute technologie
invariablement
est reliée à l'argent et au pouvoir.
Dans les années 1960,
des événements se sont produits
au milieu de l'effervescence d'alors :
la création en France
des ateliers populaires,
aux États-Unis
de la presse underground,
même au sein de l'armée,
les fantassins,
ceux qui faisaient la guerre
sur le terrain,
ont commencé à tirer sur leurs officiers
et à publier des journaux clandestins,
à l'aide de ronéos.
Mais là, on va dans l'autre sens !
Agnès citait Yuval Noah Harari.
Il présente un avenir
avec l'intelligence artificielle,
reliée au cerveau humain
et un avenir technologique
qui conditionne notre monde
et qui créera d'autres types
d'inégalités et de luttes.
La question est:
où trouver les alternatives ?
Une partie de l'attraction
des interactions
entre le cerveau et la machine,
vient de la croyance
de certaines personnes
qui prétendent que nos cerveaux
sont simplement des ordinateurs,
une pensée tirée de la théorie
du computationnalisme d'Alan Turing
où l'on considère l'ordinateur
comme un fac-similé
du fonctionnement du cerveau.
Il n'y a aucune preuve de cela.
Si vous voulez comprendre un bâtiment,
regarder le réseau électrique
et le réseau de plomberie,
ça ne vous apprendra rien
sur la façon
dont les gens vivent dedans.
Une partie de cette attraction...
Celle qui concerne
l'interaction cerveau/ordinateur,
vient du fait
que certains arguent qu'à l'avenir,
on sera capables
de télécharger notre cerveau
sur une sorte de disque dur,
nous rendant ainsi immortels.
Votre corps va mourir,
mais votre esprit survivra.
Il sera attaché à une machine.
C'est une sorte
de christianisme high-tech...
C'est la promesse...
- De la vie après la vie ?
- Exactement.
Je pense...
qu'une des choses que les gens
doivent réaliser de façon urgente,
c'est leur propre mortalité.
Une fois cette mortalité comprise,
on trouvera le but
à notre propre vie,
à ce que l'on doit en faire.
C'est ce que votre vieux patron
Jean-Paul Sartre a dit:
"La vie en elle-même n'a de sens
que par l'engagement."
Je crois que c'est vrai.
Espérer que l'avenir
soit déterminé technologiquement,
ce n'est pas nouveau,
c'est quelque chose
qui existe depuis toujours.
Ça fait longtemps que je n'avais
entendu quelqu'un citer Sartre.
Excusez-moi, je suis un vieux.
On va prendre quelques questions
du public.
J'ai une dernière question.
Cette statistique que je trouvais
absolument étonnante en 2000 :
il y avait 65 900 journalistes
aux États-Unis
et 128 000 personnes travaillant
dans les relations publiques,
un pour deux.
En 2015, 15 ans plus tard,
le nombre de journalistes
a diminué d'un tiers, 45 800,
et le nombre de gens dans les RP
s'est accru,
atteignant 218 000.
Donc, il y a un journaliste
pour cinq personnes en RP.
Ça révèle quoi, sur notre monde ?
En tant que journaliste,
je trouve ça effrayant et fou !
C'est effrayant,
mais ça vous montre aussi l'urgence
liée à la fabrique du consentement
qui est de plus en plus pressante,
et vous montre que l'urgence
de travailler avec un public informé
est de moins en moins une priorité
pour les structures de pouvoir.
On peut voir ces statistiques
de plusieurs façons.
L'une d'entre elles,
c'est que les gens
ne sont pas intéressés
à comprendre le monde
dans lequel ils vivent.
L'autre, c'est que, peut-être,
ils sont intéressés à comprendre le monde
et qu'il faut mettre sur le terrain
plus d'ingénieurs du consentement
pour qu'on puisse traiter ces désirs.
Je ne pense pas que les gens
aient perdu de leur curiosité,
et ils n'ont pas perdu leur colère
face aux injustices du pouvoir.
Trump, c'est l'homme de paille
qui peut mettre en place
un cirque visible
dans les médias à travers le monde
quotidiennement.
Mais dans les coulisses,
ce qui se produit politiquement
est horrible,
et c'est quelque chose
qui fait partie d'un plan conservateur
aux États-Unis
et ailleurs aussi depuis longtemps.
Ils n'ont jamais eu de rabatteur
capable de se tenir devant les foules
et les détourner
des véritables problèmes de leur vie.
Parce que l'inégalité économique croît,
la répression de la souveraineté populaire
par le vote croît,
les salaires des cols bleus
sont en train de stagner,
alors que les revenus des plus riches,
pas simplement le 1%
mais probablement les 10 %,
assurent la formation
d'une classe moyenne supérieure
qui sera le porte-parole
des politiques conservatrices.
Et pendant ce temps-là,
ailleurs,
on lutte contre le chômage,
pour une assurance santé
et contre des tas de problèmes.
Ces gens sont justement menés
par le bout du nez par ce rabatteur.
Ils sont très réal...
Et je pense qu'ils sont...
J'ai rencontré des gens qui m'ont dit :
"J'aurais voté pour Bernie Sanders,
"mais j'ai voté pour Trump,
car ça ne servait à rien."
Ça vous montre à quel point
les gens sont manipulables.
Ils ne peuvent plus faire la différence
entre l'un et l'autre.
Un creuset des contrariétés
est désormais bien palpable,
tout comme un sentiment
de s'être fait voler ses droits,
ce qui peut se traduire
de différentes façons,
l'élection de ce Président impossible,
par exemple.
Si vous regardez
ses meetings depuis 2015,
il n'était pas difficile
de voir qu'il deviendrait Président
en raison des sentiments
qu'il fait jaillir chez les gens.
Dire aux gens...
de tabasser tous ceux qui le critiquent,
par exemple :
"Autrefois,
on vous aurait sorti sur un brancard !
"Allez-y, cognez-le !
"J'aimerais vous mettre mon poing
en pleine tête.",
dixit le Président.
"J'aimerais vous cogner,
cognez-le, allez-y !
"Et je vous enverrai mon avocat
en cas de procès."
Sauf que maintenant,
son avocat est poursuivi aussi !
Merci.
Il doit y avoir des micros...
Des remarques ?
Bonjour,
vous avez dit dans le film que les gens
qui ont lancé cette propagande
n'en verraient pas la fin,
que ça durerait pendant des générations.
Qui pensez-vous est l'instigateur
de tout cela ?
C'est une question importante.
En partie parce que des tendances
plus progressistes dans notre société
ne voient pas le long terme.
Nous avons ce désir
pour des satisfactions immédiates.
Si on parle d'individus...
En 1936, lorsque Roosevelt
menait sa campagne présidentielle,
il dirigeait une guerre
contre la classe des affaires.
Il les appelait
les royalistes économiques
et disait:
"On va leur enlever leur pouvoir !"
On le voit un petit peu dans le film.
Et à la fin des années 1930,
il y a différentes organisations
qui se regroupent,
l'une d'entre elles
mentionnées dans le film,
c'est l'Association
nationale des industriels,
toujours très puissante aux États-Unis,
comme les chambres de commerce,
au pouvoir tout aussi important.
Il y avait aussi un groupe
qui était intéressé
par la création d'une identification
entre la chrétienté,
Dieu et le capitalisme.
Une des raisons pour lesquelles
sur nos billets il est écrit :
"In God we trust."
Bien que provenant des années 1930,
ce n'est arrivé sur les billets
que dans les années 1950,
comme le développement d'organisations
telle que la Société du Mont-Pèlerin,
ou le département d'économie
de l'université de Chicago
qui ont vu la vitalité du capitalisme
et sa longévité comme étant en danger.
Ils ont établi des plans
et instillé l'idée
de la vision à long terme :
même si on ne voit pas la fin
de ce qu'on a créé,
il faut le créer quand même
et avoir confiance en le fait
que ça va atteindre son but.
Pour répondre à votre question
plus directement :
qui avait été recruté par l'Association
nationale des industriels ?
Un jeune acteur de Hollywood
du nom de Ronald Reagan.
Et Ronald Reagan,
durant les années 1940,
est devenu un porte-parole
contre un système de santé national,
qui était sur le point d'être voté.
Et puis, il a travaillé
pour General Electric.
Il avait un tuteur,
quelqu'un qui le formait,
et il passait d'usine en usine,
arguant contre le syndicalisme.
General Electric est devenu
une des premières grandes entreprises
à développer des stratégies
pour démanteler les syndicats.
Reagan est passé à la télévision
dans les années 1950,
avant General Electric.
Il présentait une émission :
The General Electric Theater,
dont le slogan était :
"Chez General Electric, le produit
le plus important, c'est le progrès."
Dans les années 1960 et 1970,
il a été élu gouverneur de la Californie,
puis en 1980,
il est devenu Président des États-Unis
utilisant largement
l'ingénierie du consentement.
Il préfigurait déjà l'avènement de Trump,
en quelque sorte.
Il n'avait pas la dureté de Trump,
mais il avait une politique similaire
et présentait les mêmes intérêts.
C'est un exemple d'idées
qui bouillonnaient déjà
dans les années 1930,
mais qui ont fini par s'imposer
dans la sphère présidentielle
dans les années 1980.
Depuis,
elles continuent de dominer.
Le parti démocrate, par exemple,
s'éloigne de sa tradition
des programmes d'aide sociale
qui étaient l'héritage du New Deal.
Je considère Ronald Reagan,
et maintenant,
disons, son fantôme idéalisé,
comme un exemple
de cette vision à long terme.
Où est la limite
entre cette idée qu'il existe
cette ingénierie du consentement
à long terme très efficace,
et les théories conspirationnistes ?
Si on est véritablement manipulés
dans un domaine,
l'est-on pour tout ?
Peut-être que personne
n'est allé sur la Lune ?
Peut-être que le 11 Septembre
ne s'est pas produit ?
Toutes ces théories qui traînent...
Où est la ligne de séparation ?
J'ai un problème
avec cette expression :
"théorie conspirationniste",
car tout historien
sait qu'il y a
et qu'il y a eu des conspirations.
La papauté a été expulsée de Rome
et exilée en Avignon
à cause d'une conspiration.
L'assassinat d'Abraham Lincoln
n'a réussi
que grâce à une conspiration
visant à éliminer
le leadership de l'Union,
par des anciens confédérés.
L'expression "théorie conspirationniste"
est entrée
dans notre monde
plongé en eaux troubles.
On ne peut pas étudier l'histoire
sans prendre en compte
les réunions de certains groupes,
sur Madison Avenue, par exemple.
Comme nous le faisons aujourd'hui.
Tout ça est totalement planifié,
bien entendu.
En fait, aucun d'entre nous n'est ici.
On a une petite clé
derrière l'oreille droite
et on a été remontés,
avant de descendre ici.
Mon ressort commence à fatiguer.
Après l'assassinat de Kennedy,
il y a eu toutes sortes de "théories"
sur son assassin,
et la position officielle
du gouvernement a été
en ligne
avec l'individualisme américain.
"C'était un tireur isolé,
"pas de conspiration,
"ne regardez pas l'homme
derrière le rideau."
C'était un "tireur isolé",
qui, comme par hasard,
a été tué
quelques jours après son méfait.
Donc il ne peut pas divulguer
ce qui a pu le motiver.
Il y a des tas de gens,
de toutes sortes,
souvent dépourvus d'information,
qui ont spéculé sur le fait
que l'assassinat d'un Président
n'est pas quelque chose qui se produit
sans quelques discussions préalables.
Et donc les termes
"théorie conspirationniste"
sont devenus un euphémisme
pour "idées folles".
Je pense que la façon
qui nous permet de faire la différence,
c'est l'investigation.
En d'autres termes,
ce qui différencie le bon journalisme
du journalisme fumeux,
c'est que le bon
est basé sur la recherche.
On regarde partout,
on soulève les pierres.
Il faut mettre les mains
dans les ordures, regarder tout ça,
mener une enquête comme un inspecteur.
Et les gens devraient
être capables de le reconnaître.
Mais le fait que cette expression
"théorie conspirationniste"
soit agitée à tout-va
et n'importe comment,
même pour décrire Trump...
Trump est plein
de ces théories conspirationnistes.
Il dit avoir vu un groupe d'Arabes
dans le New Jersey,
qui faisaient la fête sur un toit,
lorsque le WTC s'est écroulé...
Mais en réalité, il n'a rien vu.
Il n'était même pas dans le New Jersey !
Ce genre de choses se trouve,
aujourd'hui.
Pourquoi cette idée
que des groupes de gens
travaillent de concert
les uns avec les autres
pour comploter ensemble ?
Je ne pense pas
que ce soit sain pour nous
d'ignorer la façon
dont des intérêts croisés
fonctionnent dans l'Histoire.
Vous avez posé beaucoup
de bonnes questions.
Je pense que Bernays a été enivré
par l'idée de contrôler les gens.
Sa fille, Anne Bernays
que vous avez vue dans le film
et que je connais,
lorsqu'elle était à table avec lui,
l'entendait dire
que tout le monde était stupide.
"Vous êtes stupides !",
lançait-il à ses propres filles.
Il pensait que la minorité intelligente
avait la responsabilité
envers la démocratie
de s'assurer que les masses stupides
se comporteraient correctement.
Il y avait beaucoup d'argent
impliqué là-dedans.
C'est ce qui pousse les gens
à promouvoir la guerre
contre leur pays d'origine.
Il n'était pas...
Bernays n'était pas
un membre éminent
de la Commission
sur l'information publique.
C'est une façon de revisiter l'histoire.
Walter Lippmann et Arthur Bullard
étaient des conseillers
du Président Wilson.
Wilson voulait utiliser la force
pour faire taire l'opposition.
Lippmann et Bullard ont argumenté
en faveur d'un bureau de la propagande.
Ils sont devenus les architectes
de ce bureau
et ont choisi un homme
qui s'appelait George Creel
pour diriger la Commission.
George Creel était un journaliste
qui avait fait des révélations
sur le rôle de Rockefeller
dans le meurtre de mineurs,
dans le massacre de Ludlow, au Colorado.
Il était connu
comme un détracteur des industriels
donc sa nomination était intelligente,
car la guerre était souvent vue
comme une guerre de businessmen.
Bernays était un exécutant,
et absolument pas
un architecte de la guerre
contre l'Autriche.
Comme de nombreux intellectuels
américains,
il faisait partie
du "Crépuscule des idoles",
Ces intellectuels
qui se sont mis en conformité
avec l'effort de guerre.
Au sujet de l'immortalité,
je comprends ce que vous dites,
il reste des enregistrements de nous.
On était soit mort,
soit vivant, avant.
Et puis soudain, on a été enregistrés.
C'est une espèce de lieu intermédiaire.
Je l'ai déjà mentionné à Pierre Haski,
en parlant de mon père
lorsqu'il était mourant.
C'était un homme très visuel,
mais il est devenu aveugle.
Ma mère lui avait acheté
un petit enregistreur.
Il parlait tous les jours
de son état nauséeux ou intestinal,
de ses rêves,
du fait qu'il ne voulait pas
être morbide,
de ses souvenirs avec son propre père,
quand ils allaient
aux bains-douches
dans le Lower East Side...
Mon fils, qui est monteur,
a mis tout cela sur un CD.
Ces petits souvenirs sont devenus
des petits fichiers sur un CD.
Je les avais mis sur mon iPod.
Alors que j'allais rendre visite
à un ami,
j'écoutais de la musique et soudain,
j'ai entendu la voix de mon père !
C'était incroyable.
Je suis donc allé voir mon collègue,
et je lui ai dit:
"Ce qui vient de m'arriver est inouï.
"J'écoutais de la musique et soudain,
"mon père a commencé à me parler.
"Je pouvais entendre sa respiration
et sa voix."
C'était tellement différent d'une photo,
qui est gelée, morte.
C'était en fait...
Je comprends
qu'il existe une sorte d'immortalité
possible à travers ça.
Mon ami s'est emballé et m'a dit :
"Mon père est mort
quand j'avais 13 ans,
"et je donnerais toutes mes photos
"pour un enregistrement de lui
en train de me parler."
Donc, bien sûr,
ce territoire intermédiaire existe,
mais ce qui est différent au sujet
de l'immortalité dont vous parlez,
et qui sont les données enregistrées,
c'est le fait de transformer
les sujets en objets.
Cette immortalité-là,
c'est l'immortalité d'un objet.
La subjectivité a disparu.
Le mythe du transfert du cerveau
vers un disque dur,
promeut
le maintien de la subjectivité,
on vous promet que votre esprit,
votre conscience subsistera.
En réalité, elle sera transformée
en données exploitables
par d'autres.
Donc, je n'appellerais pas ça
"immortalité",
dans le sens où certains l'entendent.
Merci pour ce témoignage personnel
très pertinent au vu de notre sujet.
Nous devons mettre le holà
avant que votre ressort ne s'arrête.
Merci beaucoup, Stuart.
Merci à tous pour cette discussion.
Je voudrais vous dire
que c'est un des grands plaisirs
de ma vie
d'être ici avec vous.
J'ai 73 ans,
et je sais que les idées
pour lesquelles je lutte
depuis que je suis très jeune
sont encore importantes,
encore pertinentes.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec l'immortalité,
c'est sur l'engagement.
C'est sur le but de la vie
sur lequel votre vieil ami Sartre
a beaucoup écrit,
et je vous remercie beaucoup d'être là.